you
all right under 10 for an hourly bullet
arena start of a stream Oh how's my
sound good it's silent for the stream
all right whoo what do we have here this
is different
f-five huh
let's this night might go back in now
he's not going back in
I want to have this night around to
support this pawn
hmm
I'll take
you
I totally missed that that was even a
move
they had a night check and I would have
lost
immediately
let's see how annoying I can maybe be
with my queen
maybe maybe this was better
yeah that pawn is a that's it's a tough
one
I'm gonna take
you
that's a mouse slip
this isn't going so well
you
yeah I'm not able to
go as fast as I would like that's not
working it was not a good idea to change
my settings before this stream we're
gonna we're gonna we're going to work
with it though
caro-kann on board
we go for a pin
I was I was slow and weak in that one
the nation
okay how is how is f/4 defended
maybe just have to push now giving me
the pond it's tricky to defend
I'll stay here
prevent queenside castle
and I guess we'll push here maybe maybe
that's an idea or not we'll sneak in a
passer
you
just gained some space on the Kings
Queen side lost track of what side this
is
a 4mm I'll do a four now this is not a
very good approach what I'm doing okay
now at least I have a secure square for
my knife it's it's a bit uncomfortable
not having that a 8 square available
guard my seventh rank I'm a head on the
clock
this guy's going to get picked up
maybe I get the bishop
okay they were way down on time okay
round three coming up still a lot of
time I am in 1546 at the moment
let's see who we got next
Kramnik
kramnik student 1 next opponent
um yeah let's go Queen c7
and I'm going to try and focus on that
square
you
you
white as a solid setup I guess they're
gonna be challenging soon c4 could be
sensitive that's one of the drawbacks
with b4 c4 square
am I really threatening to take here
Stefan what this night
slight square
ambitious very ambitious if this I have
to go back otherwise I'm gonna I don't
know comfortable pin
this isn't really the way to do it when
your opponent has that dark square
Bishop to weaken these dark squares
I said ambitious foolish is a better
word let's see if we could get away with
grabbing upon now
he's there just in the nick of time
hitting a lot of stuff
Wow fancy
oh well this was bad because they get
the rook at the end
take care take care primo after all I
have to hope for a tricky night stuff oh
boy
you
oh boy
I need some magic because I don't have
the position where's the magic
Oh God
Oh God hide
just barely guarding stuff
I should be able to get this one but
okay I know how to do this now
still a little sloppy oh man I don't
know be prepared for anything
sloppy
got a mover or non mover Val Mickey we
got a mover okay I think the night
needed to come out now this is that this
is a cook tonight move order okay we get
we got a minor
my opponent picked up upon
okay let's keep pushing
Knight g4 I have Queen here I have
enough defense
yeah let's let's maybe kill the night
hmm two pieces
I want to take none of the above let's
keep it a little closed I want some
security for my queen
just offer some trades
I'll take here because I'm out of this
there's no pin
ready to take the rook oh you know what
I just noticed something I don't have
the blue the blue arrows
why don't I have the blue arrows where's
the mate there should be a maid here
um I don't need to calculate the night
Queen here next Queen d7 ripped there I
don't I have the blue arrows I don't
know let's try you for we got blitz
bullet again
ka six come for some hippo some hippo
action okay so what have we transposed
into some Sicilian huh I guess we have a
Sicilian that is that is excellent for
me
we're gonna trade let's try like this we
got space invaders for pawns
okay I want Bishop here then I have a
connected passer f4
let's keep on pushing
you
I'm going to give the exchange could do
this why am i doing that exactly that
was such a poor decision what I did
there I allowed both the rooks to just
become free don't know why
that was an excellent position
that's a good move I was gonna play rook
g6 and hit that pawn for a third time
do I have enough now no I don't
okay
I had a check here
I think I I don't I know want to try it
I need to do sneaky stuff
turning main
you
you
so his gonzo who brutal I don't know why
I didn't give that check and then Queen
d7 I get the rug it was hanging on c6 ah
man that uh I shouldn't have that was a
very poorly time to have five advanced
very poorly timed
okay
try and play against this backward pawn
94 and then
that's a big one all right well I'll
take this
ah that was such a beautiful position
that was a pond too
this is collapsing mmm
I was ready to blunder this is covered
now we got the Queen
all right they resign him back to
tournament I don't have oh I do have a
four I was thinking I only had a couple
I only had twos because the the poorly
timed loss is okay at fifteen less than
fifteen to go I got a ten 2016 16 15 mr.
toto
haven't played mr. toto before
okay
I could get this in
fancy
um yeah
that's going to be a problem
just take him out
I'm going to be able to play here
and I support them
this is this is poorly played because
the center is going to collapse soon Oh
take here I actually have a square at
least to work with a trine in-betweener
in-betweener huh
okay
let's try opposite color bishops
they have that advanced I want to get
out of this pin really soon
off of a light square this is very
tricky now I don't know okay here and
then here
or I guess we'll go here
that bishops a great past
where I want my bishop on d4 I have this
covered I'm on this pawn they still need
a flight square
I'll go for this pawn and then run this
guy
and they catch it
they're really down in time mr. toto no
they were they didn't have enough gas in
the tank under 13
okay Gucci is in first twenty four two
fires oh they're paired up as well okay
good
in exchange French I've been pulling the
exchange French I don't know why I'm in
a in exchange French mood I guess
mode
what are we
let's change the structure see what
happens what's this night going to do
majorities have just changed and I'm
also going to win upon let's see what
happens with this guy let's keep going
hmm maybe I've gone too far okay I guess
we're gonna trade and be worse than this
ending
didn't grab that pond huh ah sneaky
oh my winning no I'm not winning the
King and pawn ending okay who has more
Tempe
can I win the Tempe game yes
yes I can oh I think they should have
done that my trouble
no no I'm not I have this this is one
there we go I think they should just
held their ground and I would have been
in rough shape
and we'll do it like this because I
could prevent the stalemate important to
take like that and give them a move
and we got mate next okay they resigned
let's bolt again alright I have to try
to get a win
gone with a three
trying to show me who's boss who's the
boss okay you're the boss you're the
boss
can we clamp down
okay let's try to get over here
I'll hop in I got a dark square bishop
mmm let's go here maybe we we pretend we
have something
just pretending I don't know man I just
don't have the answers
don't have the answers
that's just a flash move
just being flashing
I'll pick up the pawn it's worthwhile my
queen is a beast that's a rook I should
be able to win this one
we trade
I was already pre move if there is Queen
takes pawn that would be a bad pre-move
the game continues
we're gonna we're gonna we're going to
win this one
things are cool on the clock as well
put everything on dark squares we're
gonna try and be a pain ooh
there we go finally 109 okay we got fire
it's possible 20 with fire
Kuki 1 1 2 4 is still in first okay
oh not our first time playing
Scandinavian
okay what's their light-square bishop
going to do
how will this pawn be challenged I guess
like that
change the structure we're going to
change the structure we're changing the
structure and they should there should
be a problem and I want to see Queen
before
let's throw a punch at the Klean this is
this is a problem
hmm or is it
five scare the night away
where is he go
be be greedy grab a pone
take care
at Bishop b3
that's a piece right I have enough on
that oh come on that too
I'm up I'm up some material some okay
they resigned 26 24 24 with fire lu7 in
change 80 a turn here
I still don't feel confident with my
mouse I'm trying to play strong moves
but and not rely so much on the mouse
that's tough to shake okay we have an
exchange Slav if you didn't think the
exchange French was exciting stay tuned
because this is the exchange slob
this is where it's ultra exciting oh
that's a bishop
mm-hm
now it is unprotected and it's gonna be
a pain soon we're gonna sacrifice no no
no I can't let you play in my house
we're gonna try for a night here oh how
do you get out of the pin
million-dollar question
94 a chopper Oni a resigner okay 29-28
let's bullet is in oh those are two got
paired up again the one in the three
seat are paired up oh yeah right here
berserk blitz bullet is in berserk mode
now drew drew his next game against mr.
toto
kramnik student is gonna try and
definitely get me back I had a mouse win
in our first encounter try Bishop before
cleaner
is not winning a piece
all righty how's this guy gonna get
defended just like that ninety-five very
sensible
uh I don't know how I want to capture uh
yeah I do I'll go with the pond you know
we're just going to double up
you
you know my night is a pretty good
defender I'm just going to make some
consolidating moves
talk my king in and now isn't there more
pieces on this
yeah
let's jump in here
see what happens careful clean
be very careful all right let's open up
this diagonal it's a fork as well so
we're getting some material let's just
push it out of the way
grab a pound maybe me
justtake here
we got this one okay they resigned Wow
who woulda thunk it
32 with fire and [ __ ] just finished I
probably going to get paired
I have fire okay four minutes 28 seconds
collet
let's see what we got
okay that's a pun we're gonna do some
night h4 business clean exchange
huh
troilus
yeah
all right we're gonna have to we're
gonna have to defend a little bit
Bishop pear versus the knight pair who
wins
[Music]
I wouldn't mind giving the pawn back
really get how many pawns do I want to
get back I have this square covered very
important
I thought there was a fork okay let's
see if my knight could do something
exciting he's not going to get trapped
is he can't let that happen to my knight
can't let that happen these ponds are
continued to crawl 19 seconds
you
see if we get the ships going to have to
sack
they could have caught me in pre-move
mode there
you
you
you
I don't know I don't know what this
story is with this one
zooks well okay this is winning but the
mouse speed is not there I do not have
confidence in my mouse
you
you
I might have to just try and time burn
you
no I was doing all right I guess I do
not have confidence in my mouse it's
ultra shaky
okay ah you know I wanted to play see
three and reply to e6 and messing around
with that for a few games off stream I
will take now
and be a developer that's all I want to
be mm-hmm little queenside too
one stone King safety rook activity
tough to be no make a decision
they probably should take in there and
go out down into g5 why am I playing
like this
scare that night away oh he didn't want
to move
rook there would have scared me a little
bit gonna grab upon I don't mind that so
much
this guy should fall easily
with the King fighting piece 45 seconds
before the tournament is over
tournament clock f6
target f7
No
keep it simple
20 seconds
why would they welcome this exchange
seconds what's wrong with this guy
nine seconds and snuck that one in
barely that's gonna do it's very shaky
start forty with fire 34 who cares about
the fire at that point forty thirty four
twenty six twenty four ninety eight and
all
okay top ten who else is in there blitz
bullet see Johnny deejay mr. toto
boba kramnik student let's see all the
pages I good luck front door
just calling out random names crispy the
ones that are easy to pronounce you'll
notice chess base chess queen qualifier
I think I've played I have played the
qualifier before Texas frequent opponent
and
this is everybody
all right to the 97 of you it games all
you